aquí tenemos una función cuadrática y
nosotros ya sabemos que una función
cuadrática cuando la gráfica moss se ve
como una parábola ahora si yo quisiera
encontrar las raíces y el vértice de
esta parábola bueno podríamos tratar de
manipular esta expresión que tengo aquí
para encontrar las una manera mucho más
sencilla y quiero que en este momento tú
paus el vídeo e intenta es por ti mismo
trabajar con esta función que tengo aquí
para encontrar tanto el vértice como sus
raíces la intersección con el eje de las
equis y así podemos ver de una manera
muy sencilla cómo podemos graficar esta
función cuadrática que tengo aquí
muy bien ahora vamos a intentar
resolverlo y vamos a ver a qué llegaste
lo primero que quiero es encontrar las
raíces así que para encontrar las raíces
raíces lo que necesito es que esta
expresión se haga cero es decir lo que
estoy buscando es que x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos 5 x más 6 sea igual a 0 y
con esto voy a ver en dónde
interceptamos al eje de las x así que si
aquí tenemos al eje x vamos a suponer
que este es lo que voy a encontrar es
donde interceptamos al eje x igualándola
a 0 porque lo que estoy haciendo es que
james es decir fx sea igual a cero por
lo tanto no vamos a tener ninguna altura
ok y como queremos la gráfica de una vez
dibujo aquí ambos
ejes esto se le genera ya es ahora si yo
quiero que esta expresión se haga cero
entonces puedo encontrar la solución de
esta ecuación si yo
hago la fórmula general de segundo grado
o si factores esta expresión y yo
prefiero factorizar esta expresión así
que vamos a buscar dos números a dos
números cuyo producto sea 6 cuya
multiplicación sea 6 y déjame ponerlo
así cuyo producto producto sea 6 y cuya
suma o bueno en este caso cuya restar
cuya suma sea 5 lo voy a poner así cuya
suma sea 5 ahora si yo tengo dos números
cuyo producto es 6 entonces o ambos son
positivos o ambos son negativos pero
como la suma tiene que ser negativa
entonces deben de ser ambos negativos
voy a buscar dos números negativos que
su producto me dé 6 y bueno 6 por 16
pero su suma no me da menos 5 no porque
uno será negativo y el otro también me
daría menos 7 am y 3 por 2 3 por 2
productos me da 6 menos 3 por menos 2 y
su suma me da menos
por lo tanto ya está los dos que quiero
son amigos voy a poner aquí menos dos y
menos tres así que puedo reescribir esta
ecuación de la siguiente manera puedo
decir que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tomarme x menos 2 ok
déjame ponerlo con el mismo color que a
su vez multiplica a x menos 3 que subes
multiplicar a x menos 3 y esto tiene que
ser igual a cero esto quiero que sea
igual a cero y bueno si dos números
multiplicándose son igual a cero eso
quiere decir que el primero cero o que x
menos 2 es igual a cero o en su dado
caso que el segundo es 0 x menos 3 es
igual a cero y si de aquí sumo dos de
ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a
obtener que x es igual a 2 esta es una
de las raíces o esta es una de las
soluciones de esta ecuación cuadrática
que tengo aquí y aquí si sumo tres de
ambos lados de esta ecuación voy a
obtener que x es igual a 3 esta es la
otra raíz o
puedo decir que esta es la otra de las
soluciones de esa ecuación cuadrática
que tengo aquí x 2 x 3 y ya nos pueden
poner justo en esta gráfica como estoy
buscando las raíces lo que estoy
buscando es la intersección con el eje
de las x de mi función cuadrática que
por cierto yo sé que es una parábola lo
que no sé si es una palabra que abre
hacia arriba o hacia abajo al menos ya
sé por donde pasa en el eje de las x
vamos a ponerlo 1 2
3 ok y mis raíces están en dos en dos
ok y en tres ok ya sabemos que por aquí
pasa mi parábola ahora lo que quiero
encontrar es el vértice ahora lo que
vamos es a encontrar el vértice vértice
y para eso lo que voy a hacer es
reescribir esta función que tengo aquí
pero completando el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto es decir me voy a fijar en esto
que tengo aquí arriba que es fx fx igual
a equis cuadrada a equis cuadrada menos
5x y aquí hasta acá voy a poner el 6
porque lo que quiero es fijarme en estos
dos y completar el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto voy a fijarme en estos dos para
que sea un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto
ok entonces va a llegar hasta acá y lo
que quiero es que estos dos más otro
tercero meten un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto para eso date cuenta que ya
tengo el cuadrado del primero aquí está
dos veces el primero por el segundo yo
requiero encontrar el cuadrado del
segundo y para eso lo que necesito es
fijarme en el coeficiente que está al
lado de la x siempre ya éste lo divido
entre 2 es decir que el valor que está
aquí es más el cuadrado y déjame ponerlo
con otro color va a ser más el cuadrado
de menos 5 entre 2 es decir a menos 55
entre 2 negativo esto lo voy a elevar al
cuadrado y pues no te puedes corroborar
que éste realmente es un tema cuadrado
perfecto ahora si esta expresión de aquí
esta expresión de aquí que por cierto me
da 25 entre 4 25 entre 4 lo estoy
sumando la estoy agregando entonces lo
que necesito es también quitarla
recuerda que para que se cumpla esta
función esta igualdad ya la estoy
alterando al sumarle esta expresión que
tengo aquí y por lo tanto puedo sumar de
ambos lados esta expresión menos 5 entre
2 al cuadrado con de otra manera lo que
voy a hacer es quitar voy a quitar
5 a 5 / 2 elevado al cuadrado para que
la función se mantenga igual no pasó
nada y lo único que hice fue aquí
completar un tren normal cuadrado
perfecto porque ahora sí puedo decir que
esta expresión que tengo aquí y déjame
cambiar de color esta expresión que
tengo aquí es lo mismo que x menos cinco
medios elevado al cuadrado ok y bueno si
no me crees o si te hace un poco difícil
ver qué es lo que es exactamente lo
mismo que estoy aquí tú podrías
corroborar lo elevando esto al cuadrado
o repasando mis vídeos acerca de cómo
completar un trinomio cuadrado perfecto
y bueno aquí tengo fx ok esto es igual a
esto de aquí y después de esto tengo que
sumar 6 ok sumar 6 y quitar a menos 5 al
cuadrados 25 25 son créditos al cuadrado
es 4 ok que por cierto 6 menos 25 entre
4 es lo mismo que 24
cuarto - veinticinco cuartos todo esto
todo esto es lo mismo que menos un
cuarto menos un cuarto entonces déjame
ponerlo aquí o ésta no parece cuatro
menos un 4 entonces ahora si ya pude
escribir a efe de x la siguiente manera
fx fx ahora lo puedo ver ya que complete
el trinomio al cuadrado perfecto como x
menos 5 medios esto elevado al cuadrado
y menos un cuarto no voy a poner con
otro color con este aquí menos un cuarto
ok ahora date cuenta que esta expresión
de aquí es exactamente lo mismo que esta
expresión aquí que es exactamente lo
mismo que esta expresión con la que
empecé y además quiero que veas que lo
estoy escribiendo de la siguiente manera
porque aquí tengo un binomio el cuadrado
perfecto y esta expresión que tengo aquí
en rojo siempre es mayor o igual que 0
esta expresión siempre es mayor o igual
que 0 porque si yo tengo un cierto
número sea positivo un negativo y lo
elevó al cuadrado me da un número
positivo y la única forma en que
la expresión se haga 0 es cuando la
parte de adentro se hace 0
ahora estoy diciendo que el valor más
pequeño que puede tomar fx escrito de
esta manera es que esto se haga 0 esto
se cancele solamente me quede con menos
un cuarto y con esto estoy corroborando
que es el punto más pequeño que puede
tomar f x porque cualquier otro punto va
a ser que esto sea mayor o igual que 0 y
entonces algo mayor o igual que 0 cuando
le sume menos un cuarto me va a dar algo
más grande que menos un cuarto así que
lo que quiero es que x menos 5 medios
esta parte de acá adentro sea igual a 0
para encontrar el punto mínimo sea igual
a 0 y por lo tanto de aquí poder
despejar a x y decir que x igual a 5
medios hacen que esta parábola o esta
función cuadrática me dé un valor mínimo
ahora si x es igual a 5 medios de una
manera muy sencilla puedo encontrar el
valor de y que está en el vértice es
decir en el punto mínimo y como lo puedo
encontrar bueno puedes sustituir este
valor de 5 medios aquí o aquí pero para
no complicarme la vida mejor
sustituir en la expresión donde es más
fácil encontrar alguien que es justo
esta si yo pongo aquí cinco medios cinco
medios me quedaría cinco medios menos
cinco medios lo cual es cero cero al
cuadrado es cero y solamente me quedaría
con menos un cuarto que tiene todo el
sentido lógico del mundo habíamos dicho
que ya igual a menos un cuarto era el
valor más pequeño que podía tomar ya
porque esto siempre es mayor o igual que
cero ahora aquí tengo ya otro punto
cuando x es igual a cinco medios que
cinco medios es lo mismo que 2.5 12.5 y
déjame ponerlo con color rojo ok voy ser
más o menos por aquí me voy a fijar en
que james tome un valor de menos un
cuarto de menos un cuarto y para eso
supongamos que aquí tengo allí igual a
uno y un cuarto estaría como por aquí
así que me voy a fijar como por aquí y
donde se intersectan en este punto aquí
estoy parado en el punto cinco medios
déjame cambiar de color en el punto
cinco medios ok
coman menos 14
coman menos un cuarto y ya puedo
asegurar que como este es el punto
mínimo que toma mi parábola entonces
este es el punto de mi vértice ya tengo
una parábola que abre hacia arriba y
cuyo vértice es este punto de aquí es
este punto de aquí así que es hora de
dibujar lo creo que ya me siento
bastante seguro para dibujar esta
parábola y lo que voy a hacer es fijarme
en la parábola que abra hacia arriba que
toque este punto cruce aquí al eje de la
cx toque este punto y después toque este
punto y suba más o menos así se va a ver
un esbozo de mi parábola que represente
justo a la función con la que empecé es
decir a la función x cuadrada menos 5 x
+ 6 éste es un esbozo de esa parábola y
bueno recapitulando todo esto salió de
tomarme la misma expresión solamente que
vista de maneras distintas en un primer
lugar factor hice esta expresión y la
igual de acero para encontrar las raíces
ok y en un segundo lugar para encontrar
el vértice lo que hice fue completar el
trinomio cuadrado perfecto después aquí
no olvide
que esto es una ecuación y por lo tanto
si sumo aquí el cuadrado del segundo
aquí lo tengo que restar y después me
fijé que esto aparte siempre era mayor o
igual que 0 y por lo tanto para hacer la
0 igual la parte de adentro a 0 y me di
cuenta que el valor de 10 debe de ser
igual a menos un cuarto y ya está